[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Brooke and Kentucky
she says my husband listens to you every
day so it would be amazing if you would
set one of us straight here we go we got
into debt when we were in our early 20s
we found the baby steps and haven't
looked back our home is almost paid off
with no other debt kids have enough
money in their college funds and we put
15% of our pay into retirement I've
always been a at home mom homeschool the
kids and work full-time from home way to
go here's the problem when we go on
vacation I want to stay in a nice hotel
and a fancy room I work very hard and am
not happy unless this happens my husband
doesn't get it at all he says we just
sleep there why spend the extra money
financially the extra cost is in the
budget I don't spend any money on myself
it's the one thing I want to splurge on
I want my husband to recognize my hard
work and show his appre appreciation by
getting the nice room who's right if
it's me what can I say to make him
really understand oh oh my gosh number
one Brooke you're right yes you are
right oh man you're right always always
Splurge for here's the deal with a
vacation if you go back to a place you
hate it just takes away from the
vacation maybe I'm girl mathing this but
when you go to a place that you love
it CH I'm like I would cut on food
before IID cut on hotel for me
personally yeah a nice hotel or a nicer
Hotel all day oh all day look
and Rachel look I'm just listen Jade and
I have stayed in some really bad hotels
in our in our days yeah don't do it I'm
not risking finding a hair in my bed I
am not risking you know the way the sink
looks when it's old and crust like I
just yep it's not worth it it's not a
vacation and especially if you have the
money yeah okay so Brooke here's the
thing I want my husband to recognize my
hard work and shows appreciation by
getting all of this this is y'all's
money together so so like him deciding
all of it I'm like no you you get an
exact say in it and sure I want him to
appreciate you and your hard work
regardless of vacations and hotel rooms
that's really it um that was kind of the
weird that was the only weird he gets to
he gets to decide this and I don't like
that that was the only weird part about
this whole thing is I don't I don't know
that I view the vacation like when when
Sam and I go on vacation I'm not viewing
it as this is your chance to appreciate
me right I'm thinking of like okay like
this is our family's chance to get away
yes and in my opinion the whole point of
staying in a hotel is to be somewhere a
little more luxurious than where you are
right right right and don't get me wrong
everybody's budget is different but yes
I I mean once she said it's in the
budget
I'm like give me the green light it's
the green light all day I know hope
Brook we're on your team and I think
you're husband appreciating you or you
wanting to feel more appreciated
whatever that looks like is a
conversation outside of the vacation
conversation but try and you could try
and find a way to relate to him like if
whatever he's into that he would be
willing to spend money on kind of try to
find a way to parallel it like if he's
into the I don't know like golf just say
hey like you wouldn't want me to go buy
you
a I don't what is it a nine iron like I
don't know like try to find a way to
relate it be like you don't want me to
buy you a nine iron from Walmart so
don't yeah don't don't try to buy me you
know and just kind of relate it to
something he understands and he sees the
value in and maybe that'll help that's
good create your free every dollar
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life